every known Admiral in one piece has his
own devil fruit Kizer who has a low-key
Adele fruit called the pikapika Nomine
and it allows him to create control and
turn into light kuzan has a logia devil
fruit called the hia Nomi and it allows
him to create control and turn into ice
akinu has a low gear devil fruit called
the magumugunomi and it allows him to
create control and turn into magma
sengoku has the mythical Zone devil
fruit called hitohito No me model
daibutsu and it allows him to turn into
a Golden Buddha fujitora has a paramecia
devil fruit called the Zushi zushinomi
and it allows him to create and
manipulate gravity finally green bull
has the logia Del fruit called
morimorinomi and it allows him to create
control and turn into a forest human for
a full video on all the Admirals and
their powers click the link in the
pinned comment